welcome back so we're talking about data
science and data-driven inquiry and
machine learning is a major component of
data science so I'm really excited to
talk about machine learning which is one
of my favorite aspects of data science
so you've collected all of this data
you've identified questions you want to
answer where you're gonna go find the
data you've collected it stored it
you've cleaned and scrubbed so you know
that the data is good and you've gotten
rid of all of the fat-finger errors and
and and bugs in your data and so now
you're ready to build models useful
models from your data and this is really
where all the magic happens so machine
learning in in kind of the real world in
simple terms is building useful models
from data so models from data okay so
you're gonna build models hopefully that
improve with increasing volumes of data
so in most fields of science and
engineering we have increasing volumes
of data being collected because of
improved measurement technologies and
storage better you know better
experimental and computational
techniques and so what you hope is that
with that increasing volumes of data and
hopefully better quality data and richer
data your models should improve if you
are using the right machine learning
architecture for that type of data and
those questions that you want to ask an
answer okay so models that improve with
data with more data is kind of what I'm
talking about
now I really shouldn't have said that
this is where all the magic happens
because this is a huge misconception in
popular culture today is that machine
learning is magic that this is kind of
Harry Potter
you know you wave a magic wand and a
problem with data and it just gets
solved and that's really not how how
this works at all so I want to be very
clear that machine learning is in no way
magic in reality machine learning is
built on foundational advances in
mathematics and computer science that
have been happening over decades in
particular in optimization
and regression so in some sense
machine learning is also optimization
based on data so you're going to
optimize your models to fit the data to
explain the data that you've collected
and often these are going to be
regression models so if you ever want to
get under the hood of a machine learning
algorithm if you want to understand
what's going on and develop new ones or
modify or understand these machine
learning algorithms then there's some
math you're gonna want to learn linear
algebra is a pillar of data science and
machine learning in particular
optimization theory and statistics
linear algebra optimization and
statistics which regression is a big
part of statistics and these are fields
that have been developing for centuries
and tremendous strides have been made in
the last decades in all three of those
fields and so machine learning is really
understandable and you can you know it's
not magic you can understand what's
going on under the hood another aspect I
want to point out a lot of people today
think of machine learning as just just
neural networks and while it's true that
neural networks or deep learning is an
extremely important part of machine
learning so very very important aspect
of machine learning as neural networks
and deep learning that's not all that
machine learning is so I want to say
machine learning is not just neural
networks there are dozens hundreds of
other techniques optimization and
regression techniques to build models
from data that are not neural networks
and still have a very very important
place in in kind of the the suite of
techniques that you get to choose from
in machine learning okay so we're
talking about models that improve from
data based on foundational mathematical
techniques and linear algebra
optimization and regression and in
general you want these models to be
developed you know and oftentimes these
are developed from training data so you
have some data that you've collected and
you're going to build a model for how
how that data behaves what's kind of the
rules that govern the data you've
collected and what you hope is that that
model
generalizes to be useful in the future
so you train this model maybe it takes a
long time and a lot of resources to
collect the data and train the model
then you hope when you deploy that model
in the real world the predictions are
still useful and so I think about this
you have some inputs some input
variables you have some outcomes or
predictions that you want to make based
on those variables and what you hope is
that there is a correlation between the
input variables you're measuring and
these outcomes and what you hope is that
you can build this machine learning kind
of module that can learn patterns and
this data that correlate with outcomes
you want to predict in the field in the
real world okay and that's really just
kind of the cartoon of what you're doing
you're building a model for how data
that's easy to measure correlates with
things you really want to know in in the
field okay and we've been developing
those kinds of models for a long time
oftentimes an expert human will decide
on some flowchart of how information
gets processed they'll write a program
if this then this so if then else
statements if a and B then C and those
kinds of deterministic programs are now
in some applications being replaced by
these machine learning programs they
serve the same purpose but instead of an
expert human writing down the rules the
machine learning architecture is it's a
framework where you can learn those
rules or those models to be consistent
with data that you've measured and
collected and so that's a really
important aspect is that in some sense
this doesn't require an expert human to
write down all of the rules that they
know now that's not to say that machine
learning does not involve expert humans
I think of this as being very much a
tool that is human guided okay and so
that's the last thing I want to talk
about right now is that machine learning
is very much a human guided exercise and
some of the ways in which its human
guided the human gets to choose the
human expert gets to choose what quest
to ask and what data to collect what
data they think they can answer those
questions with what data and more
specifically they get to choose what
they think are the inputs and the
outputs what do they want to predict and
what do they get to measure so inputs
and outputs are really important and
then a last very important ingredient is
choosing the architecture
so which arc never can spell this live
architecture which machine learning
technique which framework which
architecture are we going to use to
learn models from data am I going to
pick a neural network a deep neural
network which one am I going to use a
support vector machine or a decision
tree and that's where the human guided
expertise really comes in so they get to
decide what questions they want to
answer what process they want to model
what's the data the inputs and the
outputs and importantly they get to
choose the architecture what type of
machine learning framework do they use
to build these models from data so we're
going to talk about these various
aspects of kind of what are the
architectures what do we want out of
machine learning algorithms where we are
going to talk about what neural networks
are so we get a little bit better
understanding of what they can and can't
do and that's all coming up